all right we're on in now hey guys i'm
ryan right
I'm Randy price we're gonna watch from
Varian comics today the history of
Deadpool the trailer is dropping today
so we thought hey we shall learn about
Deadpool a little bit first before
watching the trailer yeah we told so we
could seem like we know we're talking
about yeah cuz I think that we should
know we're talking yeah or else people
are gonna hate us cuz comic-book people
are [ __ ] dicks oh I love this channel
man today's episode of Aryan is brought
to you by Carbonite today I'm Baron I'm
giving you guys the history of this guy
Deadpool welcome to brand we love comics
more than Deadpool loves chimichangas
I'm your host eros King Llanes that
should by far one of the most requested
history of episodes for me to do which I
can't blame you guys because he's
freaking awesome so without further ado
let's get into the Merc with a mouth
history
Deadpool was created by artist Rob
Liefeld and writer Fabian Nicieza and
made his first appearance in New Mutants
issue 98 in February of 1991 Rob Liefeld
was a fan of the Teen Titan comic
apparently a fan of drawing busty
Captain America's sorry I had to your
good artist Rob what were you thinking
anyway mr. Lyle showed his new character
to then writer fabian ur cezzah when
fabian saw the costume design and heard
what the characteristics were being a
killer having super agility Fabian said
to live fell this is pretty much just
Deathstroke from the Teen Titans
so Fabian gave Deadpool the real name of
Wayne Wilson as an inside joke as
Deathstroke's real name is Slade Wilson
which is pretty hilarious it is
shameless about it in that first three
years he was hired by Tolliver to attack
cable and the new unions after
subsequently appearing in X force as a
reoccurring character Deadpool began
making guest appearances and a number of
different Marvel comics such as Avengers
daredevil and Heroes for Hire Darren a
93 the Deadpool receive his own
miniseries collagenase written by fate
intercessor and penciled by Joe
Madureira
it was a relative success and Deadpool
starred in a second self-titled
miniseries written in 1994 by Mark Waid
then in 1997 Deadpool was finally given
his own ongoing title initially written
by Joe Kelly with newcomer artist at the
time ed McGinnis it was actually one of
my all-time favorite comic artists the
series established Deadpool's supporting
cast including his prisoner slash from
other bigger blind al and weasel who's a
friend information broker and arms
dealer for Deadpool as for Deadpool's
words already gave it to you guys in the
Deadpool vs. Nightwing episode but since
today is all about Deadpool I'm gonna
give it to you guys one more time you
guys mind
no wait time have you said yeah oh well
I'm gonna get you guys anyway [ __ ] a
bit ago is wade wilson he was born a
normal person to a highly dysfunctional
family in a little town of Ohio he ran
away as a teenager and bounced around
the country all the while getting
military training from various sources
he was eventually diagnosed with an
incurable cancer at which point and
hoping to cure himself he volunteered
for a subset of the Weapon X program
that was attempting to give a human
Wolverines healing factor the experiment
ended up accelerating his cancer leaving
his whole body horribly disfigured
making his scan look very similar Freddy
Krueger he also became severely mentally
balanced thinking it was a failed
experiment that facility sent him to a
hospice with other failed experiments
from the program while there the other
prisoners will take a pool called a Dead
Pool as to how long each subject would
live weight was eventually sentenced to
death after breaking hospice rules by
killing his friend worm we only killed
out of kindness to put him out of his
misery as he was just lobotomized so
they tried to kill away by taking his
heart out let his newfound healing
powers kicked in he then escaped and
ironically chose to call himself
Deadpool now I've said before Deadpool
is pretty much the perfect mixture of
the Punisher and spider-man as he's an
antihero and doesn't mind killing just
like the Punisher and is always
wisecracking and joking around just like
spider-man but even more so than
spider-man which is how he got his
nicknames on Merc with the mouth because
he doesn't shut up especially while
fighting someone he's also a master of
breaking the fourth wall always talking
to us readers that close self-aware he's
in a comic book as he's always saying
stuff like warning this scene does not
take place in a comic or one of my
favorites from this panel where he says
none of this is really happening there's
a man at a typewriter this is all his
twisted imagination which is what many
of us fans have come to love about him
how he's alaria Saul while being a BAM
as for that Bo's powers and abilities he
has an accelerated healing factor just
like Wolverine which is actually
probably better than Wolverine so he can
regenerate any destroy tissue at a
superhuman rate so any gunshot stab
wound or as at essence falling out with
just he'll even his head getting chopped
off with he'll as long as his head is
reunited with his body
he's also immune to any and all known
diseases besides being invulnerable to
basically all types of physical harm due
to his healing factor you can also
teleport using tech from his friend
weasel and is one of the best assassins
and mercenaries in all of comic books I
mean he killed the entire Marvel
Universe even though the story wasn't
canon it was more of a what-if story and
out of Marvel's main continuity it was
still an awesome story what's funny
though is people always use the Deadpool
kills the Marvel Universe story as an
argument that he can defeat anyone which
isn't necessarily true for example
Deadpool was actually defeated by Moon
Knight in vengeance of Moon Knight issue
8 obviously he didn't die because he
pretty much can't but nonetheless he
lost the fight so what I'm trying to say
is they're characters out there who can
and have being him before it's just
extremely hard as he's one of the
toughest and hardest to defeat
characters in all of comics but Deadpool
isn't all about by
smart remarks things that go baby Who am
I kidding yeah he is but he does have a
romantic side to him Deadpool formed a
romantic relationship with the cosmic
entity death who regarded him as a
kindred spirit that pool is depicted
having a humorous exchange with the
entity in the self-titled annual
Deadpool and death Deadpool becomes
infatuated with death after he has a
number of near-death experiences and
starts trying to kill himself to join
death flash forward a little ways during
the funeral for a freak storyline death
appears to reciprocate the feeling but a
jealous Thanos prevents Deadpool from
dying and joining the entity and curses
Deadpool with immortality so yeah she
was a TMZ with death literally but let's
not forget what Deadpool is most in love
with and that would be Mexican food or
more precisely chimichangas which you
can blame them chimichangas and Mexican
food is amazing Dec will also actually
has a Deadpool family who all originated
from an alternate reality and not the
main Marvel reality earth-616 you have
lady pool or Wanda Wilson from Earth 30
10 out of a need to belong and feel
losses she joined the side of a group
called the rebels fighting against
loyalists in the United States there's
kick pool or little wait Wilson was born
on earth
10:33 zero and alternate reality where
he was the newest boy accepted into the
Xavier orphanage for trouble boys
there's also a Deadpool dog called you
guessed it dog pool who is created on
earth 103 173 and a process similar to
the Weapon X program and finally you
have head Poole who's from Earth 21:49
another universe where all the Marvel
heroes were transformed into zombies
head cool didn't once have a body but he
lost it in battle eventually though all
the dead pools from different universes
would unite and form the Deadpool Corps
or Deadpool corpse whatever you I where
big operations it's not Avengers tower
not a Batcave not even the Hall of
Justice but it is Deadpool's apartment
but now that I've given you guys a good
amount of info on Deadpool it's time to
give you some good Deadpool stories to
read
there's Deadpool classic volumes one two
and three wave wilson's war Deadpool
kills the Marvel Universe trade
paperback Deadpool vol 1 dead presidents
Deadpool and death annual 1998 any of
the Deadpool and cable ultimate
collections like books one two and three
and of course there are many more good
Deadpool stories with that should be
enough to get you guys started
coburn it takes your pictures in your
files from a computer crash fire theft
or when you accidentally delete a file
by automatically and continually backing
up your files and keeping them securely
off-site you'll never have to remember
that whether you have one or two buggers
at home or so on actually I don't know
why she does mistrust coverage to take
their home planet computer files with
plans starting at just fifty nine
dollars a year so you're free trial at
carbonite.com with my AC code variant
shooting evasion this month if you
decide to buy that's hard I die when I'm
no good for shows month is variant
we can stop the video here okay everyone
you should subscribe to variant comics I
feel like I learned a lot here he's
awesome
I hope the Deadpool family does
eventually come in to form in this
Deadpool franchise of course if the
films are good right yeah of course but
Ryan I Reynolds I think is like the
perfect Deadpool
oh yeah he totally failing Merc with the
mouth yeah without a mouth the Merc with
the mouth the Merkel out of mouth boom
boom boom boom you don't wrap yourself I
wrapped myself I didn't know is that he
had a dog yeah that was one and I didn't
know that he was defeated by Moon Knight
so those are two things that I didn't
know hmm
otherwise I knew most of the things
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe I
wish in some way they will pair up MCU
with Fox to do this you think they would
I don't know but it's such a popular
comic book yeah it would be [ __ ]
sweet if they gave us some fantasy movie
real fast or some [ __ ] I don't know I
wouldn't even be disappointed if it was
like oh it's all Deadpool's dream or
some [ __ ] oh my god what I'll take any
wake that babies it's like man that
wasn't that's not what yeah I want to
see characters in this franchise like
the mother figure the guy who has
Arsenal what checking out this video did
was it got me excited for more
characters in the Deadpool universe yeah
I knew like basic facts about Deadpool
like his powers and whatnot but it got
me excited for were supporting
characters you know like I'm an excited
for Deadpool which is awesome because
we're all like really jack of this
movie's finally coming out which is
pretty [ __ ] excited we were waiting
like [ __ ] forever for this movie is
gonna be awesome
I really had fun everyone walked away
from x-men origins Wolverine going when
Ryan Reynolds was Wade Wilson he was
[ __ ] awesome now what they did with
him at the end of course but when he was
Wade Wilson he was awesome and and that
was like the number one thing people
walked away with so finally at sea this
is a [ __ ] movie and of course they
couldn't like probably scratch a lot of
that out like not really care because
depo can make some joke about it yeah
about how no one [ __ ] likes it cuz he
does that in life
the teaser trailer you know anyway guys
uh thanks for tuning in and referring me
to this channel if you're new to my
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects if you're new to brandy price
you can check out her channel and
contemplate whether or not you want to
subscribe with me don't think about it
just do it um you could follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter and her
on those sites too and me on vine and
periscope follow us on these social
networks cuz if we get more followers we
can get more product placement well I
can get more product but as machine gun
[ __ ] yet but I am rolling in money money
yeah in a few hundred bucks